مدينة
في وسط غابة هو ما يقوله كثير من
الناس في المرة الأولى التي يشاهدون فيها
وسط المدينة وأتلانتا المساحة الهائلة من
المساحات الخضراء التي تكون في هذا الوقت من العام
مذهلة ما لم تكن لديك
حساسية بالطبع
[موسيقى]
أنا  باكتشاف أن أتلانتا هي مدينة نشطة للغاية في
الهواء الطلق ومثالية للأشخاص الذين يشاهدون
الجرأة ، وأقول إن اكتشاف المشاهير من كل
نوع
في مركز فن الدمى
أجد بعض أشهر الدمى
على هذا الكوكب.
ويذكرني الفن إلى أي مدى اندمجت
الثقافة في نسيج أتلانتا ،
لذلك سنجربها مع الدمية ،
هذا السيد الزغبة ،
إنه أنيق للغاية على ما يرام ، لذا فأنت
تريد فقط التأكد من أن يدك
على طول الطريق جاميكا كولينز  هو السماح
لي بالاقتراب والشخصية مع السيد الذي
يحضره إلى الحياة مد يد المساعدة إذا
كنت
سترغب في معرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا القيام بذلك مرحبًا ،
ها نحن
قد أيقظ الطفل بداخلي أيضًا
أنت بالفعل  إن تناول صوتك الدمية
الذي يعجبني
حقًا لا يبدو
وكأنك تفعل شيئًا عالي النبرة ،
ولا أعرف لماذا هو جيد ، أعرف
هناك ،
انظر إلى تلك النقطة أوه أوه  مثل ما
فعلته للتو ، هل
كنت تشعر بالحزن ، لا
الرعب ، هل يمكنني مصافحتك
بالطبع ،
لقد تم تلقيح كلانا ، نعم نحن
نعم عندما أكون على خشبة المسرح وأنا في
جسدي ، أفكر نوعًا ما
شعري أو أوه ، أنا أنقل ما أحتاج
أن أنقله ولكن مع الدمية
أنا مختبئ نوعًا ما
والدمية تقوم بالعمل
وعلي أن أعيش من خلال
الدمية ، أنا متحمس جدًا ، إنه
أفضل يوم على
الإطلاق  نعم ، لا أعرف لماذا ،
لكنني فجأة شعرت بالرغبة في
التلال مع صوت الموسيقى
الآن حان الوقت لزيادة
التحكم في الدمية
التي تتطلب أكثر من يدين بشكل
مثالي ، هل أنت مستعد للتحدي
أنا  جاهز
، واو ، كيف سنصل إلى
هناك أه يجب أن نقفز ،
سنقفز جيدًا ثم نذهب إلى
أسفل المركز  مدير
tistic John Ludwig يديرني من
خلال دورة عقبة منضدية ،
نحن نعيد إنشاء فن Benuraku الياباني ،
يا
لها من تجربة ، ما
هي المتعة التي يتم اصطحابها إلى الأماكن التي لم أكن أعرف حتى
أنني كنت بحاجة إلى الذهاب إليها ،
تهانينا ، لقد فعلت ذلك ، لقد
قمت بالعمل الذي جئت معه  من أجل
الرحلة التي كانت
ممتعة بشكل لا يصدق والتي
نقلت الدماغ بعيدًا عن أي
هراء كان يحدث في رأسي ، نعم
بالنسبة للوقت الذي كنت قادرًا على القيام به ،
هذا رائع ، هذا ما كان
يقصد أنه كان
مذهلاً حقًا أليس هذا ما كان عليه العالم
من العجب
هو كل شيء عن هذا الرجل لم يكن
جيدا جدا كان هو وهو
بخير كان لديه الكثير من الحماس
الذي لا يجعلك بعيدا جدا